so we have yet another one of these just
absolutely disastrous interviews that
Donald Trump agreed to do this one with
the Wall Street Journal and if you
recall like over the last years a year
and a half these sort of longer form
interviews with newspapers have been the
absolute worst for Trump in a sense the
long-form newspaper interviews are good
for Trump in that the average Trump
astiz not really going to actually read
through a transcript from an hour
interview so when Trump says something
insane harebrained and stupid it might
get less attention but in terms of
figuring out just how incompetent the
guy is these longer form newspaper
interviews aren't particularly good for
Trump and also it's like a time limit
issue right with these TV interviews
that Trump does at some point you're
going to hit a time limit and that can
prevent some of the absolutely horrible
diversions that Trump takes were often
are where he says the craziest things
but in the past the longer interviews
with the New York Times that he did the
one he did with the Washington Post
they're just absolutely terrible and he
did one with the Wall Street Journal and
it was truly so bad that he and the
White House straight-up denied things
that he said but fortunately for the
Wall Street Journal and later in the
show I'll suggest that really everybody
who talks to Trump should be doing this
The Wall Street Journal recorded the
interview and released the audio and
we'll get to the specifics of that a
little bit later and this is where the
problem comes in Donald Trump made so
many outlandish and untrue and
fallacious and disgraceful statements in
this interview that no one statement is
really going to get that much attention
and the entire thing sort of becomes
normalized and explained away as oh it's
Trump being Trump it's Trump being an
unorthodox president or whatever
catchphrases the right likes to use
Trump in this interview talked about
everything from free trade to Democrats
to the economy foreign policy Japan the
Mexican wall were discussed all the way
to and including North Korea and none of
it really made any any sense nothing
that Trump said was even remotely
indicative of someone who even is
slightly connected to
the real world but increasingly it sort
of doesn't matter because it's become
completely normalized and then we get to
that last one that I mentioned North
Korea that's become the source of a lot
of controversy around this interview in
the original interview transcript at The
Wall Street Journal published The Wall
Street Journal quoted Trump is saying I
probably have a very good relationship
with Kim jong-un
I have relationships with people I think
you people are surprised immediately
this blows up wait wait what do you mean
Trump probably has a good relationship
with the North Korean dictator we didn't
really know that they had a relationship
and what does probably mean doesn't
Trump know whether he has a relationship
with a world leader or not particularly
someone like Kim jong-un and what is
that relationship like you think Trump
would know with certitude what that is
Trump went nuts
and said that the news corporation owned
Wall Street Journal is obviously fake
news on no other platform than Twitter
would he say that quote The Wall Street
Journal stated falsely that I said to
them I have a good relationship with Kim
jong-un of North Korea obviously I
didn't say that I said I'd have a good
relationship with kim jeong-hoon
a big difference fortunately we now
record conversations with reporters and
they knew exactly what I said and meant
they just wanted a story fake news
so the Wall Street Journal came back
after numerous demands for a correction
and they said no we're not correcting it
our transcript is correct and here's the
audio they tweeted out quote we have
reviewed the audio from our interview
with President Trump as well as the
transcript provided by an external
service and stand by what we reported
here is audio of the portion that the
White House disputes so let's listen to
the clip together and see what we are
able to hear about this a bit of the
interview with that being said President
Xi has been extremely
generous with what he said I like him a
lot I have a great relationship with him
as you know I have a great relationship
with Prime Minister Robby Japan and I
probably have a very good relationship
with Kim Jong ooh
North Korea I would I have relationships
with people I think you people are
surprised there is absolutely zero doubt
that Trump said I probably have not I'd
probably have period let's listen to it
one more time just that piece to be sure
with that being said President Xi has
been extremely generous with what he
said I like him a lot I had a great
relationship with him as you know I have
a great relationship with Prime Minister
Abbey Japan and I probably have a very
good relationship with Kim Jong of North
Korea all right I have relationships
with people I think you people are
surprised so let's evaluate this in
pieces number one Trump is denying a
recorded quote right he's saying the
recorded quote is not accurate this is
basically the epitome of gaslighting
right or of lying or of propaganda
because in order to believe Trump you
have to believe that I don't know that
the Wall Street Journal doctored it in
some way that that's not really Trump or
something right the quote is recorded
it's crystal clear from said I probably
have a good relationship with Kim
jong-un the second part is that as usual
the White House is denying these things
in a way that causes more controversy
and is more divisive and is reminiscent
of the world that exists actually an
Aldous Huxley's book a brave new world
now what do I mean by that well if the
White House came out and said what Trump
meant to say is he would have a good
relationship with Kim jong-un if given
the opportunity that would be better for
geopolitical circumstances for Trump to
have that relationship whether it's true
or not that would reduce the controversy
oh the president misspoke all right he
doesn't have a relationship with Kim
jong-un he's not claiming he has a
relationship with Kim jong-un
he just misspoke ends the story instead
they say no the Wall Street Journal is
fake news it's a lie the recording comes
out
it proves the transcript is 100%
accurate and now his supporters are back
in cognitive dissonance mode we can't
not believe Trump but the audio sounds
like the Wall Street Journal is right
well maybe they doctored it we can't
believe them they're trying to take down
Trump which is of course at its face
absurd if you were to dr. audio to make
Trump look bad you would do it on
something way worse than just I have a
good relationship I probably have a good
relationship with Kim jong-un whether
it's strategy or just the result of
Trump's narcissistic bluster this forces
Trump supporters to pick sides and plant
their feet and dig their heads in the
sand even more yeah when you go out of
your way to call The Wall Street Journal
fake news you have to be accurate about
that I mean you can't have that be
proved wrong but I think the Trump
supporters will try to rationalize this
by saying well Trump was obviously
wiretapped here he didn't consent to
this recording right which of course if
it took place in Washington DC wouldn't
be relevant because it's a one-party
consent state and if at least one party
knows that a recording is being made now
Trump is also saying that they are
recording all conversations with
reporters and they've put out a
transcript that is much more difficult
to hear I think but it's the same
transcript you clearly said this it's
just stunning
but the cognitive dissonance that this
causes is part of why I've been saying
Trump could be reelected with sub 30
percent approval hypothetically we
worked out the numbers and it could
happen which is why we need to vote
every single one of these stories gets
me to that point we need to vote the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership